whoa reads Ignatian great i'll be here
oh it's John Humphrey oh it's John
Bailey Sean Bailey here epic voice ha
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
well Gerald's game is the name of the
game the movie whatever this is space on
a Stephen King novel
yeah actually be good all right
telling the name carries weight with
more than one person goes on call back
me a call back there we go
[Music]
brought to you by cialis
oh yeah oh yeah he's got the freaking
cups gone
[Music]
so awkward 9-1-1 [ __ ] off oh she can't
get out
[Music]
okay seriously have you ever put
together a bed you could break that
sucker apart pretty easily can't get
water to my mouth
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
director of the oculus rift
[Music]
jeez doubts language film directed by
somebody completely different that's not
what I saw happening hey man don't have
a heart attack during your BDSM yeah
I'm under 27 hours - there's only two
reactions you can have this this kid
this can either really work or this is
just the stupidest thing in a long time
I could you like kick those bedposts off
my fair share of beds and look it's made
of solid iron steel and well maybe some
lumberjack Maiden and it's worth its
salt as a piece maybe the entire thing
out of one giant piece of tree yeah no
both no nothing it's just totally carved
out of a giant piece of you know why yes
solids made like it's melded together
like the Iron Throne does not look
that's that big but he's stuck in there
like okay it would hurt but you could
get out you can get out I'm sorry I
don't know I'm hoping the movie
immediately once the situation occurs
takes the time to do all the things
we're thinking so we can see yes hi can
I get two seconds of Virtua I'm like oh
I try to get it over
apparently too big I couldn't like work
on that but a little bit so I came off
obviously they did not buy it at IKEA
they've been out in two seconds but ok
well this is fun see you later is I kind
of like the concept of it yeah you're
handcuffed and then this thing goes
wrong it feels like it's trying to be
like this crazy hyper thriller what not
it just seems like such a silly kind of
cost fifty Shades of loneliness maybe I
feel like they're almost trying to
market it like they marketed hush or
something like that yes it has that vibe
and I don't I've never read the story at
its best this could be a pretty cool
claustrophobic yeah I don't know what to
mean especially if you're stuck there
for days I mean the water yeah the
bathroom like there's gonna be
situations but it's gonna be
uncomfortable I feel like every movies
that choose-your-own-adventure until
they get to that one main thing the rest
of the movie really doesn't matter all
the small stuff did they go this way or
this one but this main thing like are we
gonna be in the movie where you're
cuffed here with a crazy psycho killer
or you're just stuck here with that food
and water and you have to a bed and they
went that route yeah so I'm kind of
thinking well that is not where I saw
this going and this could be really
boring like it's super dull movie cuz
I'm thinking like you know what films
like the shallows are buried there's
this there's a very specific end game
like and buried you know he's on the
phone with someone if he can like play
this game right he can get out of it the
shallows it's her verse and a shark here
I'm like what's it gonna be I figure out
how to get out of the bed
her nurse is an awkward sexual situation
for man experiment did you do the Jeff
Bridges southern accent oh yeah this and
I'm wondering a lot because Stephen King
can also be hittin this when it comes
Steve and King resurgence and we had the
dark tower it doesn't feel like a
Stephen King movie to me it just feels
like a crappy oxygenation
it feels like an Oprah's network I feel
like when I could go bad dating movie of
the week movie a Tyler Perry film I said
I feel like hints of some King in it I
don't know the word is it King King ISM
seeing isms you know like when it's
going to the flashbacks of something
with her dad like man like yeah I was in
her and handcuffing her or something
like that that's what was causing her to
freak out which she should have just
mentioned yeah at the very top of
getting handcuffed first thing I thought
of a split I'm hoping this is
interesting but the dog suddenly biting
her I guess this is a little nod to Cujo
the dog got hungry yeah yeah I didn't
know what to make of the dog but you
know I gotta imagine most this movie's
gonna take place in that one room so I
don't know where to get hungry - so how
long does it take to get home your
report starts we don't know from the
training she's been stuck there but this
is Stephen King it'll be like three
months yeah next thing you know somebody
with an axe is gonna Mike Flanagan is
clever so I'm gonna hold off like he
does seem like he's resourceful
especially the small spit and he did you
watch where she's a filling environment
yeah so I feel like this could work out
but I also don't love this tree it might
be a bad trailer I mean at least the one
thing I got from this trailer was that
it didn't totally let you know this
movie's gonna suck or this movie's gonna
be great it was gonna die you can't let
you thinking this could be good or bad
but it could be good this is what's in
the box all over again and it's really
does this will run heavily rely on carla
Gugino doing a good job are you guys
excited for Gerald's game I kind of am
his game went terrible there's a
Terrence Jame maybe this is his game and
he's just faking his heart attack that
would be a crazy I don't know what
happened all the ways to get out of a
marriage one man had a plan
subscribe you the real rejects click
that notification bell yeah John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram become
a patron Oh Jack today
epic voice guy over here just patreons
voice ha support check out his channel
link in the camera cut ox I could just
edit it to go to the rest of the word
box but I'm gonna keep it like that box
what's in the box